let's uh let's start with the story
let's let's see what's going on over at
military comm they say China sends
aircraft carrier near Japan Taiwan as US
Navy struggles with coronavirus now that
the way I see this is you got it like I
think everybody wants to be very careful
about how they phrase things okay and
I'm obviously way over the top and my
title like it's literally just a boat
passing by and people wave to each other
but there's there's escalating tensions
that have been going on for a really
long time especially in the South China
Sea yeah and it's not just physical war
it's it's cultural war I can't remember
what movie it was I think this was like
a Pixar film it was like a viral thing
where like a little girl walks past a
map and then the map shows the South
China Sea has dotted lines around it
which is China's claim to the South
China Sea and it was in like a Disney
film yeah I forgot they went back and
changed it in a kid's movie yeah what
movie was there what they like added
after the fact yeah they went back yeah
seriously after they were using Chinese
animators and so they were like china
says ours so it's but there's what
people to understand about the moves
that are happening in this region that
they lasered us you know apparently like
showing they must locked on target or
whatever they sank a fishing vessel
they've been doing that yeah when did
that happen
that's like eight weeks ago two weeks
ago talk about it they sank a Vietnamese
fishing vessel right right
so I mean tensions are there and now
with the US Theodore Roosevelt
evacuating all of these personnel
because of kovat and the tensions with
the you know the commander of the ship
or the captain or whatever you know
there's these are all moves meant to
like poke and prod so this is the story
right they say that China sends an
aircraft care you got to understand at
least as far as I can tell and I'm not
you know I'm not like an expert on what
China is doing but it feels like a prod
okay girls like they just flicked our
ear like we're gonna do about it you're
gonna do anything or just like taking
one step over the line
yeah and then seeing what we do oh
you're not doing anything all right I'll
I'll fully stand here now I'm not going
back I'm just pushing a little further
in yeah I see it as a mosquito oh no no
I couldn't he got away
I'll see if I can get him all right the
you know we'll get him yeah the UFO go
all right check is that they say Japan
and Taiwan kept watch on the Chinese
aircraft carrier Li awning and it's
strike group as they streamed through
the Miyako Strait and past Taiwan over
the weekend of
according to the Japanese Ministry of
Defense and published reports Monday the
Liao Ning and five accompanying warships
passed through the 155 mile wide
straight halfway between the Japanese
islands and Oki of Okinawa and Miyako on
Saturday turned south and past East of
Taiwan on Sunday according to reports
the straight is wide enough to qualify
as an international waterway the Japan
maritime self-defense force tracked the
Chinese aircraft carrier to guided
missile destroyers two multi-role
warships and one supply class fast
combat support ship as they passed 262
miles southwest of Nagasaki's dong zhuo
islands about 7:00 p.m. Friday according
to a Defense Ministry Joint Staff
official whoa that's more than just it's
it was a strike group yeah well I don't
so is it a show of force
we responded yeah like we did what they
call what you mentioned was like an
elephant one elephant walk yeah we're
like well actually I don't know I've
read into this and I don't know if it
was a response to this I mean that that
does make sense timing wise but it also
makes sense that they had to take every
book every thing off the ship because
the ship was coronavirus basic oh yeah I
got it so they had to like take
everything on when was this so the
elephant walked this was the 13th and
the report of the China destroyer this
was the 13th as well as well as having
at the same time same time yeah exactly
so it's not just China going like you
know trying to make you flinch yeah I
think it's alternate to each other more
like you know lunging at each other Lex
in it you know what you ever have
somebody like lunge at you real quick
try make you fly yeah it's like two
dudes at the same time then it bumped
their heads you think we'll get lucky
and they'll just knock each other out
that would be lovely
because thence the third party nearby is
gonna freak out and fire a missile and
then also and everyone's firing missiles
and then everyone's lost their minds
well I guess the fight wouldn't happen
because they would just knock each other
out head but no but it would be like two
guys flinching at each other but with
like 30 guys behind them gearing up to
fight yeah yeah and then when they both
get hit and the other the other people
have no idea who hit who so they go out
and they start swinging and punching
each other and well in that situation it
sounds bad all right check this out here
do they say around 4 p.m. Saturday the
care
groups streamed to the straight
according to official some Japanese
government spokespersons traditionally
speak under the condition of anonymity
we continuously checked those ships by
sea and air the official set the
Taiwanese Navy also sent ships from
swell to monitor the strike group as it
passed the island on Sunday according to
the South China Morning Post which cited
the Taiwan Ministry of Defence the six
vessels sailed east of Taiwan according
to the Japanese outlet sanke News which
also cited the Taiwan defense ministry
the Liao Ning is the only aircraft
carrier currently in the western Pacific
however the USS America a smaller
amphibious assault ship that carries
f-35b lightning to stealth fighters is
underway in the East China Sea according
to its official Facebook page okay they
renounce on Facebook we're heading there
at is he the US carriers three at
Theodore Roosevelt and Ronald Reagan are
in port both dealing to some extent with
the novel coronavirus the Roosevelt is
sidelined in Guam where much of the crew
are undergoing isolation to stem a
corona virus outbreak yeah that's where
the Elephant Walk is in Guam so that
makes sense yeah so maybe they're doing
it because the ships it's a twofer
crippled basically so the like we want
to flex our muscles yeah look what we
got don't mess so that sounds like it
sounds pretty obvious that you know what
I mean like it's like I do with a broken
leg flexing its muscle like look how
strong I am it's like dude your legs
boss you know chase me I'm running away
with your stuff now why your legs broken
check this out so this was the story
that was reported the other day
u.s. Navy evacuates over 80% of USS
Theodore Roosevelt crew as nearly 600
carrier sailors test positive
coronaviruses this is brought up in the
story they say as of Sunday 4309
Roosevelt crew members had been tested
for the virus of which 585 tested
positive according to a navy update
about four hundred sailors awaited
testing do they have that many crew
members at one time four thousand that's
a huge I don't know if they're all
stationed at the same time you know they
could have like revolving hundred forty
hundred at one time is that it
huge yeah and how many aircraft care how
many carriers do we have one we have a
twenty we have eleven yeah more than
this this surprised me to learn we have
it seems like very few aircraft carriers
yeah but I no one else has more than one
I know but I think this is why the
captain was such a big deal when he was
talking about how weakened they were so
does this this it says here the smaller
amphibious assault ship that carries the
f-35b lightning to stealth fighters that
sounds like a aircraft carrier but they
don't say it
right so maybe they're not considering
all of the ships that have you know
aircraft as considered aircraft carriers
right we have to like carry a certain
set amount know also he like this you're
right I feel like we gotta have more
than eleven but think about what they
are but wait there's a möbius units
doesn't fit go underwater what does that
mean if fighters on it's like you know
it makes me sound - a fantastic voyage
of some sort ventures movie yeah
whatever they got though the shield
shield fire slash island yeah I know
right
they say the the positive cases aboard
the Roosevelt account for more than half
of the total eight hundred ninety
sailors have tested positive for the
virus across the Navy meanwhile the
Reagan undergoing maintenance in its
homeport of Yokosuka Naval Base since
November is preparing for deployment
officials with task force 70 the battle
force of the seventh Fleet in a post
Sunday to its official Facebook page
said sailors the task force are
undergoing 14 days of sequesteration
prior to departing on patrol more than
1,000 sailors assigned to the Reagan and
its accompanying strike group were bused
to yo Kota Air Base and Naval Air
Facility Atsugi over four days last week
to sequester themselves prior to
deployment according to the task force
70 post so the other thing we're seeing
here u.s. flexes its military strength
with Elephant Walk of b-52 bombers and
drones in Guam yeah look at them after
China takes advantage of US aircraft
carrier being crippled by coronavirus
dude they're photos of this yeah Wow
look how thick that looks these are P
fifty twos
yes Wow those are old though aren't they
I don't know if the ships themselves are
old no no the b-52s I mean they could be
new b-52s
I guess yeah same same style aircraft
but we got Navy mh-60s Nighthawks
US airforce rq-4 Global Hawk Navy mq-4c
Triton Air Force b-52 Stratofortress
--is so I guess they're like new you
know that we a Stratofortress come on
let's just talk about how great that
word is do you know anyway moving we
developed a new gravity bomb like
several years ago it was a big story and
I remember I think this may be like even
6 or 7 years ago at this points been a
while but gravity bombs are there
they're nukes you just drop like the
original bombs that we dropped on in
Japan
yeah it's a gravity bomb you just fly it
over and you drop it yeah and then since
then we've developed intercontinental
ballistic missiles and multiple
independently targetable with multiple
warheads but we made this it's a Megaton
bomb and it was really really small ok
so I'd imagine these bombers have I
don't know make sure they're clickable
I'll put it this way even I'll tell you
what if you came to me and said Tim
here's a press report saying they don't
have any nuclear gravity bomb
capabilities I'd be like I don't believe
you I don't believe you yeah I don't
know I wouldn't believe it I agree
I don't believe check this out so they
have a map actually look at this the
Elephant Walk came just days after China
sent its aircraft carrier the Liaoning
and fighter jets close to Taiwan so you
can see where the USS Ronald Reagan just
a little tiny amphibious thing is out it
is and the Theodore Roosevelt they have
it on this map I think this map is not
scaled properly yeah I think my mom is
way further south isn't it yeah and
that's probably why it's in this weird
little window box right but you know
China sailing a strike forced past
Taiwan yeah what is it like why I don't
know what are they moving it out there
for the show of force show of force
I mean position it yeah that's a - it's
like you know I show up force or are
they positioning for something why not
both yeah why not both who makes the
first strike in any kind of conventional
warfare that's the really interesting
question and why would they do it so
some people are tweeting you know bit
hyperbolic China has sank a US aircraft
carrier or disabled or whatever some
people actually saying sank
and they're saying that it's they're
exaggerating to an absurd degree but
with the coronavirus you know and how
they lied in the World Health
Organization you know also lied there
they're saying China did this and
they've disabled you know an aircraft
carrier by doing it that's a big deal so
if their numbers are legit like China
says we only have two thousand who have
died because they're authoritarian
lockdown and they barricade people in
their homes I don't believe them
but through the deaths that happened
from barricading people in do you think
that that should be considered a corona
virus death even though they don't die
from corona virus cuz they're opening
the doors and people are dead right
that's the issue with the authoritarian
communist country right a virus dead we
killed them we don't need to report
those numbers to you not correct if I
related we did it that sounds like
someone is saying that's actually the
North Korea joke they were like there's
a fake kim jinhwan on twitter oh yeah it
was like at North Korea Kovac cases one
and it was like then it was like three
hours later yeah zero three hours later
one throughout that r0 that sounds like
what they would do but so Donald Trump
has announced this is actually the big
breaking news but I'm I'm really just so
over all the covert stuff to be honest
like well we have a segment prepared you
know what we're talking about it oh this
is interesting
well that Trump's it pulled up yeah yeah
check us out you want to read it yeah
sure
Donald Trump freezes all that's all us
funding for the World Health
Organization accusing it of accelerating
the pandemic by opposing his partial ban
on travel from China and putting
political corrective nough supply saving
that's interesting because throughout
all of this the whu-oh does seem to be a
puppet of China it totally it feels like
they're catering to China's every whim
Japan said it it's called them the
Chinese Health Organization yeah it's
not the World Health Organization it's
like I don't understand why they have
said what they've said like they're the
ones who are like don't worry I don't
asks don't worry about it
you know you know I'll tell you what I
think it is it doesn't spread from
person to person really where did you
get that information what I said so Oh
China told you thanks for letting us
know
w-h-o and so why do you why would any
organization do that why
with the NBA do it why are companies
bending over for China honey they're
placing a bet hmm who they think wins
out in the end
yikes that should never be a
consideration like I'll say it right now
I would never bend the knee for China
but these companies do you know why a
part of them says hey Minh China might
win whatever's going on we want to make
sure on the right side it we're on the
right side of you know it's kind of like
they don't want to they don't want to
well I'll put it this way there should
never be a circumstance in which you
doubt your own country okay where where
you actually think you're gonna lose so
you're gonna go side with the enemy
yeah that's insane treasonous isn't it
well for now we're not at war with China
although I think there's probably some
kind of like shadow or cyber war going
on for sure
yeah but as long as no official
declaration but I'll tell you what
there's no war in the traditional sense
right right if there was this is a new
world we live in though yeah it's not
it's not ever gonna be the same you know
I'm like you said there's not gonna be
troops on the ground it's not gonna be
us us fighting them ha let's fight with
knives maybe look man I don't see how
people who find in the front line still
carry knives right you're right that's
true you ever watch but what are the
front lines what when has there been
like a you know uh two countries going
at it like at war you know like we are
in Afghanistan I know but that's that's
not necessarily the same right that's
going there and like Saudi Arabia and
ourselves essentially you know I don't
know a lot of details on all that so
it's hard for me to even talk on that
but when when when it comes down to
complete desperation yeah something will
happen I mean I mean you called this two
months ago yeah look called what that
China was gonna use this because their
their backs are against the wall and
they're either gonna go to war or ask
for help but we're not there yet I know
right for you know we're not there yet
but it doesn't seem like they're gonna
ask for help they're pushing they're
putting us because they think they're
strong and so they're flawed like dude
they have been pushing on the South
China Sea for a long time yeah and no
one has done anything about it
oh we flex our muscles and they put
their toe in the line and they look at
us and then we flex our muscles
and then they step over the line and we
flex our muscles and they keep doing it
you know that's what they've been doing
they just sank a Vietnamese fishing
vessel we talked about it last week no
one did anything about it they've got a
concentration camp full of wheat your
Muslims no one do anything about it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you